the f-150 lightning
is the iphone
of
pickup trucks like it's not new new
we've had pickup trucks before but this
is the first very clearly in a new
generation that will all be different
and so lightning also lightning
so
[Music]
okay so if you've ever driven around the
united states and just looked for more
than a few seconds you'll find it
impossible not to notice that there are
ford f-150s
everywhere and it's not just on
construction sites it's on the roads
it's at grocery stores it's taking the
kids to school it has been the most
popular vehicle not the most popular
truck the best selling vehicle in
america for the past 30 plus years in a
row and it shows and so that's exactly
why the f-150 lightning is a really big
deal especially for ford it's kind of
like you probably know someone like this
people who have older iphones who are
not really considering getting any other
phone other than a new iphone don't
really know which new iphone but
eventually they will upgrade to one of
the newer iphones it might not be you
and i but there's a lot of people just
like that here with their ford trucks so
i've been driving and living with the
all-electric f-150 lightning for a
couple days now enjoying its tons of
features living in a world of an
electric pickup truck and i am very
impressed but it's not me they have to
impress it's the whole world of f-150
loyalists and pickup truck buyers that
are waiting for the next convincing
f-150 upgrade before they buy one again
basically if the future of cars is
electric
then this
is one of the most important cars in the
world
so in a lot of ways it doesn't actually
matter
how this thing drives like i could talk
to you all day about driving dynamics
but most people buying a truck like this
aren't too concerned with that but the
fact is it is actually better than a
regular f-150 in a couple of ways one
it's much quieter
you can turn on the propulsion sound
which i haven't but it's very quiet for
a truck and then two
it is much smoother i'm a big fan of the
one pedal driving option a lot of evs
don't have the option you should always
have the option this gives you that so
the regenerative braking is pretty
smooth the pedal calibration is pretty
smooth
and overall it's it drives pretty well
and if you want to kick it in a straight
line you definitely can
this happens to be the first f-150 with
independent rear suspension and that's
actually just a result of the way they
built the car with the battery pack
underneath but otherwise it drives the
same way as the other f-150s if you're
used to a big truck it drives like a big
truck if you're used to being high above
the road it's still high above the road
and that's actually important it's got
to feel familiar it's got to feel like
the truck you're used to and in so many
ways it still does just a little better
but clearly it does not look too out of
place on a road i drive past other
f-150s all the time it looks exactly the
same from the outside if you don't look
at the badges if you don't know what to
look for as far as the bar
headlights and the bar tail lights yeah
this is very much familiar and that's a
good thing it's supposed to be we just
need an ev version
of a car that's already very well
accepted
and ford did that with the name mustang
but
they really did it with the entire truck
here with the f-150 even if nothing else
is different about the f-150 lightning
against the gas f-150 lightning the one
thing it does have
is called the mega power frunk which
will make a lot of sense if i open it it
beeps for a second to let me know it's
going to open
then it opens to reveal
400 liters or 14 cubic feet of enclosed
storage which pickup trucks normally
don't have that's bigger than the trunk
of a toyota corolla so it's a real trunk
you can put up to 400 pounds of stuff in
here there is a false floor at the
bottom underneath which you will find
space for your charging cable but even
without that there's plenty of space for
bags grocery shopping you can fit a full
set of golf clubs in here like i've done
in the past but it's also called the
mega power frunk because you can kind of
just operate again work out of the front
there's four full-size outlets over here
a usb-c port a a port or if you just
want to use it as a tailgating but
what's the opposite of a tailgate
whatever as a cooler you can fill it
with ice and there's a drain hole in the
bottom so this becomes the place where
you sort of
party out of your truck it's just
multi-purpose in every way but really
the cherry on top is this is the feature
that would visually differentiate it and
make it obvious that this truck was
different from the others like this
would pull up in a parking lot alongside
all the rest of the other trucks there
and no one would bat an eye unless you
recognize the badging or the tail light
bar or the headlight bar you wouldn't
know but the second the front truck
opens that's when other truck owners
heads would turn like wait that that's
not the same thing as a truck i have so
that is the main
fun part
of the lightning's
mega power frunk
you can also fit a human body in it so i
could point out the work truck theme and
how it's present all over the f-150
lightning but it would also be kind of
redundant because that's all over every
f-150 you know spray-in truck liner how
massive this thing is all the measuring
equipment on the side but my favorite
part is definitely how many power
outlets this thing has and everything it
can power because it's essentially a
giant
battery bank probably the biggest
battery bank you'll ever have so the
trunk has a whole bunch of 120 volt
outlets it has a 240 volt outlet that's
your power tools your air compressor
whatever else you want it to be but then
the inside of the cab you've got
full-size outlets in there too usb ports
wireless charging the frunk like i said
also has power but the best part of it
is the truck
can power your house
if you wanted it to so ford sells an
inverter you put it in your garage and
you plug this thing in and it can back
up your house if it loses power for days
at a time
several times the size of a tesla power
wall so
that's pretty sick i guess the point i'm
making is even though i'm not in the
market for an f-150 lightning i love
this thing some new evs are super
different from the rest of the company's
lineup but as i keep saying this one's
basically the same and that's on purpose
of course the similarity in parts makes
for much easier cheaper manufacturing
which by the way is already top-notch
from the company that literally invented
the assembly line
and the familiarity of the f-150 brand
lends itself to people being more likely
to give it a shot but also not only is
this just another f-150 but it's the
best f-150 ever made the f-150 lightning
is more powerful than the most powerful
gas f-150 it has more horsepower and
more torque than the best gas f-150 it
has a massive max towing capacity the
most covered cargo space the most
high-tech features it has the least
maintenance it's the least expensive per
mile to run and own and by the way it's
the fastest quietest smoothest and the
easiest to drive if any of that matters
to you so it delivers it delivers on the
promise and i can see it making a lot of
the pre-order holders happy we even used
a second f-150 lightning to shoot this
first f-150 lightning so it's already
putting in work my only question going
in was about range you know you might
have remembered some of the things left
unclear from my impressions video so
this extended range version promised 300
miles i lived with it for a week and i
found that real world use gets you a
little bit below that which is not
surprising about 280 but then there's
even a sick feature that measures how
much you're either hauling or towing
with a built-in scale and then adjusts
your estimated range from there which is
a great idea for a truck which we'll be
towing and hauling all the time so here
we are ford's gonna start shipping these
we'll see how fast they can ramp up
manufacturing
and now it's up to the rest of the
competition the electric ram the
electric toyota tundra even the cyber
truck the ones on the horizon it's up to
all of them
to catch up
to this one
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]